foreign
and good evening to our audience as we
get the presentation started here
I would like to welcome everyone
to our session how to start a cyber
security career in six months with
iiit Bangalore I have with me Professor
sridhar
um from
The Institute and
you'll be helping us go through
the advantages of a cyber security
career
now PS2 can help you so
let's begin with a overview of the
agenda for today's session we'll be
talking about cyber security careers
why they are
such an important option for people
today what this program offers uh being
the program offered by the
IIT iiit Bangalore and how it gets your
job ready
enrollment steps then your questions and
answers
so
my name is Stuart Creek by the way I'm
marketing is an executive here at simply
learn we deliver a program
um in
partnership with
iiit Bangalore so we're the delivery
partner but um
the curriculum and
faculty partner is of course
The Institute so Dr Streeter if you'd
like to introduce yourself that would be
wonderful
thanks sir thanks to that and welcome
everyone morning evening afternoon
whatever the time may be uh so uh good
to have all of you attending this
particular webinar and thanks to Stuart
for setting the context
um so we at uh
AIT Bank load we also call it the strip
light bandalore so we at triple it
Bangalore in collaboration with simplina
or offering this Advanced executive
program in cyber security so I am
faculty in charge of the continuing
professional education at flighty
Bangalore located in
uh in the Silicon Valley of India
Bangalore just opposite to the Infosys
campus
so we I basically I am a part of this
and variety and public policy and
providing Bangalore I deal with
regulations
telecommunications ICT regulation but
also significantly evolution
uh so with this brief background uh we
will go into some of the details of the
program that we offer uh next slide
that's true
yeah and we'll be talking about the
careers in cyber security so
yeah I'd like to go yeah sure so cyber
security uh it has become very important
in today's context uh in fact uh the
covet actually accelerated a lot of
activities
such as for example we've got from home
um you know people have been involved in
education such as what you will be doing
remotely and a lot of activities have
moved into digital space you know for
the physical space to digital space and
this has also accelerated the
uh incidences of cyber security so uh
you know cyber security affects all the
stakeholders
with you and me
this is government and and uh all the
areas
cross industry verticals transport
Health Care in fact Healthcare saw a
huge increase in cyber security
incidents in the recent years
um because of covet and because of lot
of data being transmitted digital they
also see in the impact of cyber security
or critical infrastructure such as for
example the gas line in the U.S which
runs from Mexico to East
was what's happened because of serious
security incidents ransomware these are
all becoming prevalent in today's
context
and therefore it is very important that
we address cyber security not only from
the individual's point of view but also
from the business that you work for also
for the society that we live in you know
apart from uh things going from physical
to digital some of the Technologies such
as for example mobile and internet of
things have also accelerated
the adoption of digital Technologies and
at the same time increase the
vulnerability of digital systems as at
large so cyber criminals
or not only playing Havoc
with our digital lives but also creating
a lot of problems for the state you know
the state the governments are also
becoming very very vulnerable to sign
the security incidents so it is in this
context that we have floated this
particular program on Executive program
and cyber security uh the next ones to
it
so uh there are a lot of cyber security
skills that are vital in today's
environment for example the first one is
the security infrastructure specialist
for example uh most of the Enterprises
will have security infrastructure
successful example firewall
intrusive detection systems and so on so
he requires specialists in order to
configure them manage them administer
them and so on
um we have also seen a lot of demand for
application security analysis you know
for example if you're running an
application a web application or a
mobile application it is prone to
security
intrusions and
example cross scripting and things like
that are very very uh to get they can
create havoc on web
based applications and therefore
um Specialists who focus on the
application layer of the
protocol are very important for
detection of security introductions
cyber security software developers it's
not only a management of administration
of security infrastructure but it also
involves
coding cyber security programs for
example there are a lot of products even
startups are you know in fact if you
look at the startup industry some of the
fastest growing software
startups were becoming unicorns in
today's context or in this cyber
security area so they develop products
which cater to specific areas you know
for example cyber security for finance
that may be a little bit different from
cyber security for transport and so on
so uh
scripting cyber security software is a
very important skill that is indeed in
the marketplace
Network Security Consultants you know
systems do not work alone so
um
yeah so there is a message which says
that I have to be a little bit louder so
I will put my bike here and hopefully
you can hear that so uh Network Security
Consultants
all the systems are interconnected not
only within the business organization
such as intranet but these are also
connected to outside through the
internet uh and they you know with that
connects for example the businesses with
consumers and businesses with suppliers
and so on so network security becomes
very important how to define the
military zones how to put in critical uh
components in the network so that
intrusion security inclusions can be
detected in time for example distributed
denial of service is a very common
network security threat how do we
prevent that from happening so all those
are possible using network security so
the market requires an average number of
network security consultancy today's
context
Cloud security arguments
today most of the applications and data
are moving away from impromise to Cloud
right so when you move into Cloud there
can be private clouds public clouds
semi-private and semi-public clouds in
which case you it is quite possible that
your Cloud infrastructure that you may
not be adjust for you it may be shared
and there are vulnerabilities in the
cloud systems as well so uh moving to uh
from improvised to Cloud also increases
the need for cloud security Architects
and Specialists
um
malware analysis you're probably aware
malware is one of the common
security intrusions security
breach incidents that happen and
therefore there is a lot of Need for
malware analysts understand what the
vulnerability of your software system is
how to prevent Warfare from infecting
your
systems
preventing ransomware and other malware
to come into Network systems and all the
new models
uh I'll we'll answer these questions uh
afterwards when we complete the
presentation so security analysts blue
team members for example we want uh to
take proactive actions right so it is
very very important that we drill we
drill ourselves to an extent that any
possible intrusions in future can be
detected so we want for example ethical
hackers no team members who prepare
the security environment such that the
inclusions can be detected well in
advance
there are threat Hunters who basically
look out for civil security threats
which can come from anywhere in the
world and then find out what its impact
is on Information Systems so
um all these need specialized skills and
cyber security skills cannot be just
inculcated by reading books and things
like that so we need us to have some
experience and that's where this
particular program stands out in
collaboration that's important uh next
one Stuart
so we need up-to-date skills for cyber
security career and as we have discussed
before uh there are all a lot of
different uh skill sets that are
required ranging from Information
Security application security network
security team always and so on uh all
the way down to for example ethical
hacking threat hunting and so on so it
is in this context that this program
will help you so this program will
address
most of the topics that we find here and
along with the concepts and theories
that are associated with each of these
themes Hands-On practical experience
will also be there according to put your
theory into practice
uh next word Stewart
voice is not
clear I'm trying my best as to what is
the voice okay
yeah the voice uh is sounding okay from
this end so I I do recommend
um I did recommend to folks that they
should uh check their WebEx audio
settings I apologize for the limitations
of the WebEx platform
um and we will be moving to zoom in
about a month or so but
um I'm going to launch this poll and I
would like to let everyone know if
you're watching on YouTube streaming
that um you can put your answers into
the comments but for people on WebEx you
can put your poll answers into the poll
widget
and
if you're about uh 30 seconds to answer
that
so what are the reasons that you have
not yet
engaged or enrolled in a program to
become a cyber security expert
because you haven't found a program
that's got a fully comprehensive
curriculum covers all the skills that we
talked about
um is it because you don't feel that
you'd end up with the Practical
experience that would demonstrate that
you're competent in the field
it because of difficulty learning
self-paced recorded videos or is it a
scheduling problem so let me present to
you the result from the poll
and over half of the respondents said
that I don't feel confident that they'd
end up with practical exposure and
experience that they could then
demonstrate to potential employers
so
going to um
go ahead and talk about
program that we're
offering
with triple it Bangalore
the advanced executive program in cyber
security
and this program
does offer a comprehensive curriculum
uh
pressure Street and I will discuss
um
aligned to Industry needs and
uh
Professor srinar is very
familiar with the requirements of
Industry because of the
close
cooperation between industry and triple
ITB
um integrated case studies and Hands-On
projects happen within the same online
learning platform
as the live virtual classrooms
all of this is delivered to your desktop
or laptop you can access much of the
content also from your mobile
and
available to you 24 7. the main
requirement is that you do have to show
up for the weekly live classes
um
but everything else can be done on your
own schedule
at any time there's support both help
you with
questions doubts blockers at any time
that you're working you can reach out to
your instructor you can reach out to
your peers through the bulletin board
feature the community chat and then you
can also reach out to our 24 7 support
staff for questions both about the
platform itself and about the
um
content
and subject matter experts will be
available to help you so
this is how we've designed the program
the QR code is for our streaming
audience to be able to access the
program page but in the meantime
um
Professor if you'd like to um describe
most of the points here on this slide
and I'll talk about the last one
yes
so uh you know some of you have shown
some from the poll that we can gather
that you don't have practical exposure
and you're not sure whether you are job
ready or not so that is precisely the
reason why
um we at Triple A to Bangalore along
with simple leader will provide you both
theories Concepts and Hands-On learning
with projects so by uh you know using
your Concepts and theory that you have
learned in in video lectures as well as
in master classes you'll be able to put
them into practice in your assignments
and case studies so that is the way in
which we develop the skill set in you so
that your job ready the second point
that you see here is the um we have we
have a third partner the national
payment corporations India and those who
are from India know npci very well and
for its very famous
um the unified program unified payment
interface UPI which has been in PCA it's
a Consortium
of Banks and financial institutions and
fintech companies so they have tied up
with npci so that in PCI can cover some
of these cyber security topics which are
relevant for digital payments industry
right so npci is a Pioneer in digital
payments in the country and I also have
learned that it is also being it's also
probably be will be adopted in some
other countries as well so uh in the
some of the master classes about created
four Master Class sessions will
being held by the Security Experts at
npci and the focus will be on securing
digital payment infrastructure and all
the security topics such as for example
security incidents incredibility
analysis infrastructure management and
which are related to the payment
industry will be held by npci security
expert subject matter experts that's the
second point that is very important
uh the third is master classes so um you
know apart from the video lessons that
you will go through
we also have master classes which
normally happens
Wednesday or Thursdays in the evening so
that will not be into 10. the master
classes will be held by a triple IDP
faculty because of course as I discussed
before three to four Master Class
sessions will be handled by NPCs
statement system now these master
classes are supposed to give
new expertise and areas that are not
covered by video message right so for
example we have an expert in automotive
security automotive security is going to
become very very important as we move
towards and trading cards and the
incorporation of 5G and 60 embedded into
EVS electronic electrical Vehicles so
automotive security is one of the very
important topics which will not be
covered in the video in a sense but it
will be covered by one of our experts
who actually
is you know worked in a Bosch in
Germany's long time and he normally
takes this particular class on
alternative scale cryptography so we do
not have specialized lessons on
cryptographing the video lessons but we
have expert cryptographers where two
excellent crypto Graphics who will take
you through the basics of cryptography
which is very very important in
essential part of security in the future
of course you will have to listen to me
because I am basically work on cyber
security noise I.T laws and cyber laws
therefore including private signals so I
take a master class on the cases that
have come up in the recent
years in India as well as from all over
the world on cyber security frauds and
intrusions and how regulations and law
are
conceptualized you know to address this
empty issues because it's also important
from a business point of view to
understand the regulations and laws
governing cyber security there will also
be a couple of classes on the ransomware
specifics of trans and where malware and
so on there is also an expert on network
security we will discuss about the
security
problems in 5G and 6G most of the
networks have migrated even in India
from our ATP migrating so
from the g25g then later on to 60 by the
end of this decade so there are a lot of
incidences which can possibly happen
which can hamper networks and the
experts are networks of indeed be
discussable so this is the third part
that is the master class with many
degrees
and of course the fourth one uh Stewart
will take you through that on the left
hand side you can see that you will get
the certificate on Advanced except the
program inside security from betting
Point board after you complete all the
course requirements including the
projects and you will also get a virtual
internship certificate from the national
payment corporations media after you
attend all the npci sessions and Master
Class sessions so uh over to you Stuart
I'm talking about the fourth Point here
yes
um as part of the program as part of our
collaboration simply learn offers job
assist career service to
the participants in the program
um this is something that begins when
you enroll and it continues for six
months after you have earned your
certificates
um of completion
and uh
go into that in a bit more detail later
but it is uh
assistance to help you focus and sharpen
your job search it's not a job guarantee
program or a placement service but it is
a
set of services that help you to put
your best foot forward in your job
search present yourself in the best
light and highlight your you found
a set of skills and tools that you
through the program
um
I'm going to ask Professor when he comes
back on in a second
yeah somebody said that if you're new to
my video at the bandwidth may be
concerned for a better audiobook so
hence
um that's fine and um so Professor if
you'd like to describe uh to the
audience yes yes
in the Silicon Valley we have we
adjusted you know it's a very important
year for us we are completing or we are
about to enter into the 25th year of our
foundation I mean we are relatively
young compared to for example the
universities and iits in the country but
we focus on information technology and
we are a dinovo deemed University which
means that we can offer
um these certificates and also degree
programs on our own
and uh
you know in fact today the Bangalore
Tech Summit is happening and we have got
the honor for serving the state of
Karnataka in which Bangalore is located
for 25 years in fact just now
director has sent a picture
indicating that the chief minister has
presented this momentum for us for
having contributed to the growth of the
ID industry in India in fact the
chairman of our Institute was
um the founder of Infosys earlier but
now it is
also from the number of enforces so we
do a lot of number of projects with
industry in fact most of the companies
I.T companies which are located here in
the city of Bangalore
collaborate with us we offer a number of
short-term programs teaching programs as
also to the industry which are located
in bank
so with this I will walk let's do it
next one
right
yeah so uh
can you go through it yeah I'll go
through this particular one um
this is a program that is uh intended as
a postgraduate program meaning that you
need to come into it with a bachelor's
degree and show that you have 50 or
higher marks uh that your bachelor's
career you uh ideally need a minimum of
one year of experience in the workforce
that doesn't mean one year of cyber
security experience this means one year
of experience uh in the working field so
that you're familiar with organizations
and how what the requirements are
uh and you do need a basic understanding
of programming Concepts you don't need
to be a professional software developer
coder but you do need to have a basic
understanding of those Concepts when you
apply for the program and we'll go
through the enrollment steps later
there will be a verification process to
make sure that you meet these
eligibility prerequisites
um
the purpose of these is to make sure
that you're set up for success and you
have the the skills the tools the
experience and the aptitude to engage in
the program successfully complete it
successfully and move on to
Career Success
so with that I will ask another poll
question
this poll question is very
straightforward which is
how much experience do you have
hold on for a moment when I get the poll
launched
oh
small technical difficulty
here we go
so
we'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
again if you're watching on the
streaming service go ahead and put in
A B C or D into your comments
and
here is the full result
so about 45 of the audience uh are
people in the less than one year
category
um so you're just a little bit
um
premature for the the program but you
will be there shortly
um and the remaining 60 odd percent of
the audience are people with more than
one year and
interesting to see that uh more than a
quarter of our audience are people with
more than 10 years of experience in the
workforce
so with that we can move on to
how this program prepares you
and I'm going to describe the learning
environment
um
yes please yes please so uh see this is
an executive program which means that
you should have completed a bachelor's
degree with 50 or higher marks and
that's a requirement that is cannot be
relaxed right
minimum of one year for experience that
is possible to relax I see that a lot of
you in fact 44 percent are having a work
experience business in here you will go
through a simple test and if you pass
the test and if you have a bachelor's
degree with at least 50 percent or
higher marks then you will be most
probably be admitted into the program so
these are three requisites so if you're
a student then you have to wait until
you graduate different
thank you
um so I'm going to describe the learning
environment if this is a program that is
delivered entirely online
um but it is not like other online
programs where you're accessing
pre-recorded material
and taking all self-paced uh instruction
this is a
Live program where you meet weekly with
your instructor in the live virtual
classroom along with your peers and in
your cohort
um
engage in uh
eight hours a week of live instruction
directly interacting with the with the
instructor with your peers in the
classroom going through the exercises
your instructor will be asking you
questions you'll have the opportunity to
ask
instructor questions and
so this is a
an online learning program but it's
based on live instruction there are
parts of the program that have
pre-reported materials that you will be
asked to
uh look at before the class session or
after do you have other
parts of the program that are projects
pests and labs that you do in the same
online
learning management system
so this learning management system
allows you to see
all the courses of the program
in sequence it unlocks access to each
one as you complete the one before it so
that
go through the curriculum in a set
sequence and so that you have the skills
to succeed in the next course before you
start it and then you conduct your
virtual internship project through the
same learning management system and
uh
and uh
npci
partnership system
you do that project again online in the
virtual environment
throughout the program
learning management system gives you
access to your community chat board so
that you can interact with your fellow
students gives you access to
Communications with your instructors it
gives you access to Communications with
the support uh on a 24 7 basis so that
you can get any problems questions
blockers resolved as you're working
and it allows you to unlock the various
certificates that you earn through the
program at each step including the
all-important final certificates of your
virtual internship and the program
itself
uh this is the
structure of the curriculum and
Professor if you wanted to describe this
that would be good
yes yes so um
you know it builds on the sessions are
uh you know structured such that you
build on your previous module so these
are module wise given here and so there
are modules and Enterprise information
security web application ransomware
ethical hacking cyber security which
will internship and so on so these are
stacked up so that you can move
seamlessly from one module to the other
module uh there are also these are core
components you know whatever you see in
um you know right right from orientation
session to cyber security virtual
internship with the core uh program
courses there are also electives uh the
electives are listed on the right hand
side for example I um uh you know
security governance and framework is one
of the elect approaches that I offer and
that's there that will be there in the
platform for you to go through it as an
elective it's also a cloud security
elective which lead to ccmp SP
certificate
apart from that there are also uh to
play the B Master Class sessions uh
which will be on topics which are not
covered in the core courses like what I
in indicated earlier automotive security
cryptography Network Advanced network
security an advanced Transit there and
so this is the way in which the program
is structured and there will be video
lessons and Associated
um case studies and assignments for each
of these modules over close to it thank
you
and the program
includes the use of not just the
exposure to but the use of a whole Suite
of different cyber security tools
techniques platforms Frameworks in order
to give you the Practical and hands-on
experience
with these different
skills and tools so that you're using
these in the projects within each course
and then in the final virtual internship
you integrate all of these different
skills that you've learned into that one
final project and this is a great thing
because it allows you to list onto your
resume
not just buzzwords about tools but
actual experience
people so when you make an example that
you claim to be skilled with Ubuntu you
can say this is how I used it
um this course working in this project
so that you demonstrate that you have
these skills and
that's very important
IT addresses the concern about having
real experience that you can show off at
the end of the program to do
potential employers and the virtual
internship is
a key to that because this is a
industry-based
problem that you will be guided in
solving
you come up with a solution you create
and encode the solution and
you will have the mentorship of uh
instructors and experts from uh PCR to
complete the program
and uh to
keep you from getting stuck any dead
ends or blockers during that three to
four weeks that you're doing the
internship
and at the end of the process you will
have something that you can show off in
your portfolio that says yes I am a
cyber security practitioner this is an
example of my work so it's very
important because you're coming into
this as a
did you enter into the cyber security
field you want to be able to have that
proof
skills be able to show that off
demonstrate that you are in fact capable
of
doing the work in that field so uh
Professor did you have anything you
wanted to add to that
so there are a lot of tools as you have
seen in the previous slide
um you know these tools are available
for detecting vulnerabilities in systems
um detecting vulnerabilities and
networks there are also tools for doing
you know cyber security Black Box text
testing application security testing and
so on so these tools will definitely
provide you with the capabilities and a
skill set which are
required by the industry so you will
become industry ready after you deploy
you know and use these tools and also uh
in doing the project so the project
basically is the final deliverable that
builds you up to the industry Needs
Nobody used to it thank you
and actually I'll let you speak about
yourself and your colleagues as the
program advisors Professor because this
is a
simply learn delivers the program
through our technology platform but the
program is it's uh overseen and
supervised by
triple I to Bangalore and
the professor
yeah go ahead
so we have uh we have a net which
academics in it which goes through the
program curriculum and also goes through
the uh the graduation of the Learners
who complete all the requirements of the
program as part of it we also have
something called as a senate
subcommittee which basically looks at
the cyber security curriculum which are
provided by the program and also we tune
it in collaboration with simply learn
which understands the market needs we
also tune the curriculum periodically
for example I am as a faculty in charge
of continuing professional education
it's a coordinator of this lesson in
some committee and we also have
President vivek's investment is an
expert in cryptography
[Music]
Bangalore so this committee basically
has the final say on and the curriculum
any changes in the curriculum the
awarding of the marks and scorecards and
the awarding of the certificates to be
taken today
over to yourself Stuart okay
and so at this point I'm going to talk
about uh simply learns job assist
program
and
as I mentioned before this is a program
that we offer to Learners in India we do
not offer
this to uh with this program we don't
offer this to Learners who live outside
of India the reason is that this is
focused on finding uh work uh in the
Indian market but it also applies to to
any other uh remote work that you're
going to be looking for through the
program uh what it includes is access to
ongoing career development services like
expert webinars it also includes the
building up of your portfolio through
the program so that you end up with
experience that you can demonstrate and
the job assist Services directly are
provided by our partner IIM jobs
and those include access to a exclusive
job portal for
I am jobs members so that you'll have
access to that
for six months after you complete
programming or your certificate
um
that also includes the all-important
resume review and rewrite service
because in today's world automated
tracking systems include
AI Bots that be evaluate pre-screen your
resume before it ever gets into the
uh desktop of a human being so it's very
important to have a resume that is
formatted and
content
suitable for that pre-screening
process so that the algorithms
will be more likely to pass you through
to the next level this is sort of an art
form
especially when you consider that the
resume also has to remain in a form that
is attractive and attention yet getting
for
the human beings who will then see it
after the pre-screen so
this part of the service allows you to
work with a professional who will help
you rewrite your resume format it
properly so that it meets both of the
requirements of
passing through the automated pre-screen
and
passing through the human evaluation
process afterward
um
then we have one-on-one interview
service get career advice and also
direct interview practice sessions to
prepare you for not only the technical
interviews and what you might expect in
terms of questions about cyber security
but also for the soft skills and
management interviews
where you'll be coached in how to
present yourself as a team player as a
valuable member in addition to
um
staff of your interviewing company and
so these things allow you to put your
best face on your job search
and not a placement service or a
guarantee program but it is the support
system that helps you in finding that
first job after
earn your certificate
as I mentioned we have expert webinars
which simply learn runs which are free
which are available to you indefinitely
no time limit on how long you can access
these and which cover
topics in various different fields right
to have a cyber security expert
presenting
um
what are the current trends coming up
coming here you might have somebody
talking about how to get the most out of
a job search
we'll have people talking about career
strategies and how to plan ahead for
your future
you'll have uh actual
lessons in
particular technical topic so you might
have a
Master Class
a particular cyber security technique
for example so these types of things are
offered
um we do them several times a week
and
and go on definitely into the future so
this is another aspect where we're
supporting your career development over
the long run
um with that said
I can ask this
whole question before we get to the Q a
and based on what you have seen so far
would you be interested in enrolling in
this partner
and again if you're on the streaming
Channel
yes or no into the comments
a close this in about three seconds
so almost 90 percent of the folks in our
audience are
interested in enrolling and that's very
encouraging so what I will do is I'll go
through the enrollment steps
which are very straightforward
um again as
the professor has said once you start by
emailing us at ask us at simplylearn.net
we will contact you
um
let you know what materials you need to
submit and what valuation tests you need
to take in order to
make sure that you meet the
prerequisites as described
that you're set up for success in the
program
and if you pass that review you'll
receive an admission offer by email at
which point you can enroll
um
the next cohort of the program begins
I apologize for the formatting error
here but 24th November is the uh welcome
orientation session for classes that
start 10 December
six-month program that starts 10
December
um
the
these for the program one lock seventy
five thousand rupee and you can finance
that out uh with zero cost financing as
low as 58.
5810 a month
um the I I generally get the question
does that mean
just 5810 for six months no it does it
does mean that you would continue the
payments until the entire thumb has paid
off but
um it allows you to budget more
effectively
for this program
again you reach out to us at ask us
simplylearn.net we'll do at this present
moment as I will put into the chat box
both the email address and the address
of the program page
on our website
here we go
you have those links available to you
and this is now where we will begin our
q a
so
we don't need this slide steering Us in
the face
start going through
the questions
so
looking in the um
the
chat
uh Deb asked the question how much a
programming experience is required is
there a way to quantify that or what
what the types of questions are being
asked on that first evaluation professor
yeah so uh not much of programming
experience is required because this
course is not a good secure programming
in fact secure programming is of course
by itself but this is more about
learning
um the different security attacks and
then how to configure secure systems and
therefore not much of programming per
size requirement there are modules which
teach you about skill programming but it
is not much
okay
and uh Aryan asks
um
if you really have to have that degree
if you're already versed in
uh certain cyber security topics like
ethical hacking
um yeah again unfortunately the
prerequisite that he is graduation with
50 tomorrow Max so that because of the
regulation uh the that governs uh these
kind of programs we cannot unfortunately
relax
okay
um we have an anonymous comment asking
about someone who's pursuing bachelor's
science in the tier three college and is
curious to know about switching to a
masters in cyber security
um just to be clear on the one point
this program is not a master's degree
program but Professor you might be able
to advise this person a little bit about
making certain choices yes so what is
correct this is not a degree program so
you will not get a degree but you will
get a certificate from Bangalore so it
is possible that with this certificate
credentials you might be able to apply
for a master's program elsewhere and
depending upon your performance in this
particular program there may be some
credits which may be offered by the
university into which you are applying
so let me again stress that this is not
get degree program it's a certificate
okay
and
in the Q a panel we also have
how will I join from
how will I join up triple it Hyderabad I
think that that's a different type of
question than what I originated
both of these institutes started at the
same time we are different
um I will address one aspect of that
question if you are a student from from
other institution during your bachelor's
degree and you want to start this
program it does not matter where you
live or where you got your degree
um within India you are able to join
because it's delivered digitally and
online you can join from anywhere
um technically you could join from other
countries as well the difference being
that you don't receive the job assist
program Services if you are for example
joining from uh
African country or North America or
Europe that type of thing
um simply learn does offer courses
worldwide
and some of you may be joining the
session from countries outside of India
so I do want to make it clear that
the certain aspects of the course are
only
applicable to Indian students having to
do with the job assist program but the
the materials
instruction are available to any
um
talked about the
programming requirements of just
scrolling through to see if we have any
other
questions
um we have one question about a
participation certificate for this
session we don't issue a proof of
attendance for this type of webinar we
do issue those for our of the other
webinars that I showed you that are
career development
instructional
overviews those types of webinars we do
offer this patient certificates
the if you join one of those webinars on
a different topic
you can expect that Cynthia asks a basic
question
I'm not a technical person am I
a
and I still enroll so is it possible
Professor for someone to succeed if they
have the
a bachelor is that it's outside of a
technical background but meet the other
requirements
and requisites yes Cynthia I mean
definitely uh you'll have to take this
um
small tests that we give
um to assess your analytical ability and
as long as you have the ability you have
the attitude to learn it is possible
um one of the things that I should say
about this particular program offered
through simply learn platform is that it
is in the sense that if you are if you
take your you can take
uh professor your your voice is actually
breaking at this point
so that that flexibility is provided in
your
learning and therefore it is possible
that you can actually catch up with the
others um who are an experts over a
period of time so I don't see any reason
why you cannot take
it but of course you need to get
qualified
right and I think your voice cut out for
a moment but I think what you were
saying is that uh
simple learns platform also gives you
access to some basic programming courses
and skills so that you can
pick on some of that as preparation
preparation for
courses in the program so you shouldn't
feel that that's a necessarily limiting
factor as long as you
do meet the
prerequisites and pass the test
uh
street art asks
I'm a software testing having
15 years of experience and if I enroll
in this program will I get a job in
cyber security
but I can answer part of that and I'll
let the professor
answer
give his answer as well the first part
is this is not a guaranteed Employment
Program our job assist is to help you
find the job in cyber security
we make no representation that you will
find a job just because you graduated
for the program
we make the representation that you will
be qualified to work in the industry
when you complete the program
Professor do you have a comment on that
yeah just to uh indicate what has
mentioned earlier that is a huge supply
demand Gap in the information and cyber
security and market so
um you know if you do while under
program
the chances of quitting a job was quite
high but since you are already a
programmer you might have a different
expectations and things like that so
that team you have to see how you can
piggyback on your existing of experience
and leverage that
uh and Roger asked the question
um
how much weight
do lawyers give to an eye a triple ITB
certificate compared to for example and
EC Council certificate
uh see this is the certificate not based
certification Body by but by an academic
Institute and therefore uh wherever you
know for example uh specifically I mean
of course you can always do
certifications by certifying authorities
and
you will be in a better position to do
those certificates certification
programs after you impact me into this
program uh so I must say that there is a
distinguishing feature we are an
academic Institution are partnering
would simply learn to deliver these
courses and therefore wherever it is
academic credentials are important this
will be valid
and I think we'll take the last question
from harsh veteran
um who has asked several times if this
is a free program or not and I think uh
reiterate that this is not a free
program this is we fed the fees earlier
at one lock seventy five thousand so
that is the cost of the
a certificate program so I want to be
clear about that
um
with that I think
we'll move on if we haven't gotten to
your question I apologize but we have
reached about the end of our hour
so
with that I will ask one last question
of you and the audience
this last question is if you are
planning to enroll in the program how
soon would you like to do that so let me
ask
final poll question
we'll leave this open for about 20
seconds
the course we like to say that if this
is something that will
improve your life in your career it's
worth considering doing sooner than
later
it's always a matter of personal choices
and
what your life requirements are at the
time
curious to know
here is the poll result
quarter of the audience plans to enroll
immediately so we encourage you to
email ask us at simplylearn.net and
inquire about getting into the
orientation on the 24th of November
another quarter is looking at joining
within three months so you'll want to
again
email us and ask about when the next
cohort is after that
the rest of you uh who are looking at
six months or more out
we encourage you also to email us to ask
about when
the cohorts or plans for future dates or
how frequently these cohorts begin and
then you'll be able to uh stay in touch
with us and get back in touch when it's
time for you to enroll so with all that
said
I want to thank
Professor sridhar for being here today
and be generous with his time and his
expertise
I want to thank everyone in our audience
today
and I want to remind you to email us at
ask us at simplylearn.net if you scan
the QR code that'll take you to the
program page on our website
and
be able to contact us through that
channel as well
and we look forward to welcoming you
into the triple it Bangalore learning
community
um
again we appreciate you taking the time
this evening to be with us
and that concludes our webinar for this
evening
so what use somebody down up thank you
very much
take care